dms
dating apps i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince
i believe in grilling them i'm gonna be
going on a series of dates to find who
can really well me this is thrilling
my name is christopher savage i'm a
personal trainer
and a stand-up comedian so i'm funny and
i'm fit
all i get is sightings and i've fed up
with them
see the best thing about women is people
in general you gotta ask them about
themselves
then they start talking [ __ ] about
themselves and then they feel that
you're interested even though you are
i'm generally interested
believe that i don't really like stuck
up women that's not my thing you know i
mean prudish
i like that's why i like the grilling
because i'm a gorilla i will grill a
girl and i hope that she can
take the grilling that i'm going to give
her to you know i mean
i'm ready i'm ready no god can't test me
hello love you all right hello stand up
man give me a hug and a kiss
god it's too soon sit down we're asked
clark
i see you got me a drink though yeah
cheers but i ain't that too soon because
you don't know our drink
well we drink wine okay i'm fine well
all right
you're in charge today how are you i'm
great thank you how are you i'm all
right
and your name is uh cheyenne no it's
rude to keep a lady waiting right
you think so how long how long was you
waiting for long enough oh really
also you're tough like that you're
always gonna be late you know what my
life is quite a busy life
i try to have things on time but i guess
certain things are just
you can't predict time sometimes you're
always late in life do you know what you
are right
you're a lovely woman but you're you're
trying to be all hard on me the
sophomore
yeah this is me being nice no you're not
knocking me something
i've just come i'm just trying to like
you here do you deserve it
yeah i'm trying to like you because
you've got a pretty physical
structure which i you you look like a
singer have you
are you on social media do you sing no i
don't think really
you've got that look though you've got a
real beautiful look so i just want the
personality to match that looks
beautiful nice sweet talk we've got you
everywhere chris
do you have a big dip do you know what
yeah
depends on what how big you mean because
that's small then
wait wait wait yeah let me explain you
couldn't say what a big dick is
however a big dick to you might be small
to you because your pom-pom might be big
she asked me how big my tickles you know
but i don't mind that because that means
that she's up for the beating
so what is your dick big it depends it's
fun size
fun size that's small fun size is when
you can get and
have fun with it and still enjoy it
without feeling
pure pain up in your ovaries like you
might not have no children is that the
type of big dick you're talking about
ovaries how big is your dick women do
like to talk about men's penis but they
never ever seem to look at their vaginas
why is that
what are you any or outie you can't ask
me questions
okay sorry i was like a day goes well
who knows so you don't know if you're
naughty
you don't like it when it falls out
and it drags along the floor no we're
not here to discriminate women
what's wrong with women's vaginas some
of them look horrible
it's like how you think some dicks
shallow and it shallow you asking me
about the size of my penis
what about my personality but it's weird
out when girls always talk about
how big is your dick and then you ask
them how big is their [ __ ]
they get vexed but i want to know
whether i'm going to fall in your poom
pump or not
whether i'm going to end up in narnia
you say well right you seem like a nice
guy
you think so
so i'm done with men wasting my time
right yeah
why what happened to you well what
happened to me it's just men like you
you're tiring waste money like me
come with just their chat but at least
we're just starting so we're just saying
we we could progress we could that's
what i'm saying you've just assumed
you've just stereotyped me straight away
no but this is why i'm trying to date do
you think you can impress me i think so
i think so it depends on you though as
well you've got to be able to
open up and let me in i can open up
not sexually though that's fine i'm just
talking about you open up and let me
just relax in and relax allow me to be
me
this is this year yeah i never change
who i am
very much for anyone that's good would
you say you're a confident man
i would like to say so yes yeah what
makes you a confident man but i have
things together
yeah like what my own place i i have my
i make
decent money how much is decent money i
don't i don't get paid a certain amount
each month
but i know that when i get paid it's
decent what's decent your decent could
be different to my decent
i have enough to pay for my bills i've
already paid off for my car
and i have my own own place i live by
myself i have no children
do you want children of course how many
depends on the person
would you say a family guy i could be
depending on whether it's the right
woman or not
have you ever cheated tell the truth i
cheated on my
second girlfriend but that's because she
cheated on me it was childish it was
immature
yeah i admit but sometimes in life you
grow
you change you look at certain things
and you say oh god was i like that then
tell me i bet you your first boyfriend
compared to the boyfriend you you're
with you were previously with
i bet you've changed so much in it yeah
of course but
exactly cheating's still wrong though no
she cheated on me first though
and me as a child immature
no i i'm talking about back then me as a
child back then was like
you know what she cheated on me so i'm
gonna cheat on her but then after that i
didn't cheat on any other girls she
deserved it i felt it
nobody deserves cheating oh come on
darling so if your man cheats on you
tell me you're not
but i'm not going to be paying treat
back really yeah i feel like that's
hella toxic
back then yeah i respected the fact that
he was honest about cheating in the past
however i don't know if he was just
telling me what i wanted to hear
would you say is that is that how you do
it if someone does you wrong you just
want to get revenge
that was almost like 15 years ago 15
years ago so you tell me a man can't
change yeah of course he can that's what
i'm saying
so you're changed man of course i really
rated his honesty
and i do believe that men can change you
know they mature they grow up
what makes you different from all the
other men updated i don't know what the
other men were like
but i know what i'm like so i can tell
you what i'm like the reason why i'm
different because i'm very attentive
i understand just lately yeah just a bit
late
every now and then can't be perfect and
i'm sure you're not perfect
are you i'm pretty close oh wow see
that's arrogance we can't deal with it
it's not i
guess it's confident you arrogant did it
you very good i could see
your face you said you're pretty close
to perfect
yeah that's hard in my opinion no oh wow
she says she's pretty close to perfect
you say that's arrogance but i think
really she's not arrogant but she's just
saying that it's like a it's like a
defense thing i don't think she's
arrogant really
yeah i think she's just trying to
disguise she's a softie
because you're talking about perfection
on the whole aren't you babe
did you just babe me maybe i did yes
arrogance get the word babe for me
it's not that i don't like babe but i
feel like you have to
really know me i have to be your babe
you can't just call me babe on
date one do you not like confident women
i love confident women
apparently not but if someone says to me
that they're close to perfect then
that's almost a bit arrogant isn't it
how do you think the date's going so far
i think it's going all right
you're quite a a hard shell but i think
it's all just
needs to be i just think you're a bit
soft inside but because of what you've
been through what have i been through
then since you couldn't well
you said you said that men like um
you're fed up of men didn't you at the
beginning yeah
right not men as a whole though just a
certain amount so being fed up of men
is going to make you have a harder shell
isn't it possibly
so i think you're really soft and cute
inside i think your neck a little
marshmallow
do you know i think i've started to
soften her up you know i
like you see how she started she started
off hard but you see when you start
talking and she starts smiling i'm
smiling with her i know she likes my
smile i got nice little smile
she's smiling back kiki it's good
i'm loving it
oh but you're close to perfect looking
though
no i love personality so do i really
after a while yeah what if someone was
like
if you went with someone she was really
really ugly hideous didn't want to be
seen with her
but she had a nice personality you would
choose her no so
you've got the wrong card because after
a while personality there has to be a
balance because the first thing you're
gonna see from a person is physical
you don't know someone from some nowhere
do you so
you have to be attracted to something
that comes towards you
first and then the personality kicks in
but that overrides everything doesn't it
darling
it does it starts is it babel darling
which one i called you everything i
could call you qt next
because i think i call you all the
things that are nice because that's what
you are that's very kind of you
i started taking it easy on him simply
because i i really respected his honesty
he seemed sweet
he did try and make me laugh a couple of
times and was successful at it so that's
when i started being a bit
nicer
no oh good answer what if i slept with
like
100 men it depends on what area they're
in
where are you from i'm from south london
all of that doesn't matter anymore
if i was maybe i'll say early 20s
teenage maybe i would be a bit immature
and be like nah she can't deal with her
but you see after a while who cares have
you ever not rated someone because of
their body account when you were younger
have you ever been that shallow
yeah because you just i'm i'm be honest
i'm talking from an immature
man's mandem point of view when you look
at
a woman that's had a body account from a
young perspective you're thinking she's
a whole
that's what you're thinking she's just a
beat but then after a while
as things mature she's grown up and
stuff like that
that's her past she could have changed
just like how i could have changed you
can't judge someone from there what did
you used to sleep about
no change from being i've changed from
being an immature man and looking at
women in a certain light
as to being a mature man and accepting a
woman for who she
is now without judging so you're grown
i would like to think so yes darling
you're an alpha
what is an alpha you tell me are you an
alpha
i'm actually an alpha female what makes
you an alpha female um i'm very
opinionated
but not a negative way i'm quite i'm
confident
as you know that's why you keep calling
me arrogant i keep calling
the arrogant oh god and sometimes i find
men can't handle me can you really you
think you can i love a woman that makes
decisions
because like i said i don't judge i make
a woman play her role whatever role it
is
if she wants to be an alpha female be
enough a female
but just respect no just respect who i
am as well
and if you want to argue with me i don't
argue that's good
no i sort things out in
conversation-wise like how we're talking
now we can sort that out without arguing
why do we have to get angry i like to go
to bed with a woman without arguing
that i don't want to be angry and have
to go to sleep and wake up the next
morning angry
sort it out reasonable would you say
you're a reasonable man i would love to
think so yes
what's that what's happening when
someone's out playing with your bum or
you're playing with someone else's ass
just take out
[Laughter]
you like yours being played with don't
mind it you freak
look at you you're so naughty
of course i like a naughty girl in the
bedroom before you said you wanted a
nice
woman no nice woman what did i say lady
in the street and the freak in the bed
that's why not even a freak on the
street but just just
quietly the balance behind the dustbin
or something
no i feel honestly
i feel that certain things in life you
need to have for you
you can't know everything about me i
can't know everything about you
i can't do nothing though like partners
you would know everything about them
no but there's vit there's certain
things like past and certain things you
just don't want to discuss with anyone
not that it's just that i feel like no
one in this world can know
you fully can they no no
i get that fully so that's why for me
and i feel like the way
i would like to date like the partner
the person that i'm with i want them to
know everything about me like what hurts
me
what makes me happy i want them to know
every detail so i feel like not having
phone password i feel like it's shady
we're talking about deepness don if i
was with you
and even if there was a little bit of
doubt just because of your own
insecurity not my actions
and i left my phone on the table would
you not try and pick it up and look for
it i wouldn't
i'm sure no because i why
why am i with you if i do not trust you
hmm why are you with me if you don't
trust me
all of that stuff that's when it starts
getting complicated yeah would you say
you're an honest man
i would say i'm honest if you ask me say
if i asked to go for your phone
then i will give you my phone but i
don't think that you should huh
i've lost it yeah you lost it yeah
oh it was quick now oh no you're not
selling dreams
you know what i refuse i refuse to sell
dreams but one thing i don't like
doing to a woman is lying and then
making her feel hurt inside and making
her cry and stuff i don't like to see
tears from
hence why i don't like arguing and i
like sort things out i just want
everything to be cool
i would refuse to tell a woman something
that's not true
that's nice
you know that's red wine right it will
depend on the relationship
so you or you don't sorry i don't know
depends on how clean you are
so you do what you don't i won't do the
fingerprints can i do the finger test
first
what's the finger test do you not think
women do that
[Laughter]
oh do women do that as well pull
i'm circumcised by the way but do you
like that
we'll go in the toilet just to check in
it before oh you wipe your
you rub your pumpkin and you smell
yourself so why give it a rick
really are you dating a girl you're
daunting i love
that was lethal blood why are you doing
that why are you asking me about [ __ ]
so at what point in the relationship do
you think yep depends on how
depends on how interesting okay so it's
on your terms
yeah which is in a way not it's not
really on my terms but in a way
isn't that good for you to know that i
just don't
yam anybody out there but if you're only
dating one person
hence why it takes a while doesn't it to
like you know get to get really
comfortable
so would you feel comfortable if a woman
didn't want to suck for a very long time
obviously you don't like it when it's
done you haven't let me
answer right now if a woman doesn't want
myself wouldn't this up my
that's understandable why why is it
understandable
oh wow you know how you wanted to show
that revenge thing you had earlier
and you was like i'll get her back what
if she wants to do that pettiness as
well like
he's not going to go down in me so why
should i suck his you be
you if you like to suck
and take it down no i'm saying i'm just
general if you like to take it in your
throat
and you like to choke then you do you do
i look like i like to take it my friend
i don't know what you like to do
the way you answer these scenarios will
determine
the way i rate you oh wow so i get
ratings what would you
do if i tell you your dad is hitting on
me
oh ask you how do you feel about it i'm
more attentive to you
and what you feel like that's really
sweet so if you tell me it's really
pissing you off then i have a word with
my dad
i'll say how dare you really of course
you'd argue with your dad
of course i'll say how dare you as long
as you're not happy
i'm not happy okay what would you do if
i wanted to start an only vans
um good question
it depends on how dirty is princess just
the odd nude people can see me naked
naked fully naked yeah oh no that can't
that can't why not do you know why it
can't run why
because everyone knows what your pom-pom
looks like but what if you were broke
you had no money and i had to have an
only fans to hold us down i have to shut
up
i'm gonna have to shut up i'm a waste
man i'm a waste man go on babe do your
thing
yes don't know your fans then if i'm a
waste man yes
if i'm earning my stuff no
what would you do if your team
is playing in the champions league and
i'm in labour labour's first
ah see ain't nothing bigger
than new birth your baby mums having
your
child how dare you be so selfish to
watch champions league how dare you
off with his head
[Laughter]
what would you do if i farted in bed
that [ __ ] don't bother me what if i'd
done a really smelly fart
do you know what you actually farting
is actually a good thing because i like
a woman
no but i actually like a woman to just
be her if you want to fart
hold [ __ ] you know when your woman hold
it in then your bellies are ah
yeah and then you end up are you talking
about fighting in your sleep
or just fighting in general yeah i knew
i'm fully awake because this is what
happened
i'll joke it off with you as long as you
let me fight on you
[Laughter]
what would you do if we were together
and i didn't like your mother
mumsy just had it in for me they say
mama always knows best but
sometimes you get smaller mothers that
exactly like to make it difficult is
your mum like that
100 no she's not that's good my mom
tends to
be very liberal so she tends to accept a
lot of people
if she doesn't like you then it will
have to be a big reason however
i feel like being the person i am i've
got my mom's personality
we tend to consult things out anyway if
you don't get on with her then i
guarantee you probably
will end up getting on with her if you
have to choose either like it's hella
toxic you're already in love we have
really crazy sex like
you think it's done dual marriage like
wifey material but your mum don't like
me are you going to pack your bags and
leave with me
never speak to your family again or are
you going to choose your family
oh never speaks to speak to my family
again yeah oh yeah
it's like babe we've got to go i can't
take this anymore wow that's a hard
question darling
i'm a grown man and i feel that i should
be able to love who i want to love
and be with who i want to be with so who
are you choosing
however if i have to leave my whole
family and never speak to them again
i'm sorry babe would you give up your
mum
for a man no there you go
exactly so you have to rate what i'm
saying haha
so chris how do you think that they went
do you know what
i think you grilled me but i think i
handled myself yeah i think you can
handle me 100
percent you know what the date went
better than i expected i thought he was
gonna have just some awful answers
you know what i think the date went
amazing so i'll be surprised to see if
he thinks i'm like stuck up because i
was a bit harsh on him so maybe he
thinks i'm a [ __ ] i like her
like a smile bit disappointed about the
whole bow cap thing
like i didn't get to see the real real
hair but i knew that there was a shell
that just needs a bit of cracking
it's weird we were actually quite
compatible i'm quite surprised
if i was a girl sitting in her position
long hair
teacher i would ask the same thing city
like attacking [ __ ]
realistically seven
seven i don't know it depends on her but
i know i did my job i answered all the
questions fine but i think
she'll probably give me about seven i'm
gonna give him a seven
because i feel like the chat was good he
was really calm he was really nice and
he was really honest
like there were qualities that women
look for women especially me
you